mobilisation ils savent qu'il y à de la
violence policière et ils veulent que
ces violences cessent selon vous 99% de
la police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il y à une impunité assumer il y a
une culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
jean castex dévoile son plan pour lutter
contre l'insécurité en france
accusé de laxisme par l'opposition le
premier ministre était en visite à l'iss
aujourd'hui c'est une série de mesures
l'extension des compétences de la police
municipale qui va être expérimenté et
quelques 150 emplois dédiés à l'action
pénale de proximité vont être créées
gerbe le sonar on est plus positif pour
coronavirus diagnostiqué le 7 juillet le
président brésilien avait passé
plusieurs jours en confinement dans sa
résidence de brasilia malgré une gestion
de la crise sanitaire très critiquée
trois récents sondages donnent vainqueur
lors de la prochaine élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
la tunisie en pleine crise politique le
président karzaï est de douane c'est
dans les prochaines heures le nom du
prochain premier ministre
eliès par phares ayant démissionné le 15
juillet soupçonné de conflit d'intérêts
il ya des partis politiques au pouvoir
ont présenté aux chefs et rittal grandi
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez sur arte france ravi
de vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
demi heure d'information rétablir
l'ordre et la sécurité voilà l'objectif
de jean castex
en déplacement à nice aujourd'hui cinq
jours après la fusillade en pleine
journée devant un supermarché
accompagné du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin et de la justice eric
dupond moretti
le premier ministre a annoncé une série
de mesures pour lutter contre
l'insécurité
pointé du doigt par l'opposition jean
castex souhaite expérimenter l'extension
est des compétences de la police
municipale généraliser la forfaitisation
des délits de stupéfiants et créer 150
emplois dédiés à l'action pénale de
proximité on les écoute que les auteurs
de ces violences sachent que nous ne
restons pas inactifs que nous
n'acceptons pas ici comme sur l'ensemble
du territoire de la république
l'inacceptable que des infime minorité
pour de basses raisons entendent faire
régner leur loi au détriment de
l'immense majorité de nos honnêtes
concitoyens la seule loi qui vaille
c'est celle de la loi républicaine et de
l'état de droit la seule autorité qui
doit s'appliquer au quartier des moulins
comme partout ailleurs c'est celle de
l'état et de la république
nous allons à la fois renforcer les
moyens de la police et de la gendarmerie
mais tout autant ceux de la justice qui
je le dis a trop longtemps été
délaissées l'important dans une peine
ce n'est pas sa sévérité
c'est sa certitude disait déjà au xviiie
siècle le philosophe beccaria l'état
faute depuis des décennies d'avoir
pourvus
la justice de moyens suffisants a laissé
s'installer
l'incertitude un déplacement d'une
partie du gouvernement aux symboles
forts selon le politologue frédéric
l'air il n'y a pas que le premier le
ministre de l'intérieur qui se déplace
il ya aussi associer le koup ministre de
l'intérieur et garde des sceaux qui est
important on a bien compris que une
grande partie de la défaillance
aujourd'hui venez de la chaîne pénale et
de et des jugements des aménagements de
peine
donc le fait que les deux ministres soit
l'as c'est un symbole important et puis
le fait que le premier ministre soit
présent ça signifie que c'est l'ensemble
du gouvernement de l'exécutif qui prend
à bras le corps la question de la
sécurité donc en termes symboliques
il ya un changement typiquement de cap
ou plus disons un renforcement de la
volonté macro nien de s'emparer de ces
sujets mais qui n'avait jamais été très
effective
jusqu'ici l'insécurité un sujet qui
préoccupe les français près de 7
personnes interrogées sur dix déclarent
aujourd'hui ne pas se sentir en sécurité
dans leur vie quotidienne selon un
sondage doxa pour fiducial un niveau
record depuis quatre ans même si à
l'insécurité physique s'ajoute le
sentiment d'insécurité sanitaire 66 %
craignent une nouvelle vague de
coronavirus la raison de ces inquiétudes
ces dernières semaines les scènes de
violence sont multipliées un peu partout
dans le pays
rappel des faits en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
holmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
direction lyon
à présent ce matin l'association vega
l'impact a organisé une action dans un
marché de la ville
les militants un souhaite sensibiliser
les passants sur la souffrance animale
un reportage luis carballo et françois
de screech offrit le prix de l'opérateur
merci et d'écouté
[Applaudissements]
faire son marché aux bruits d'animaux
massacrés dans les abattoirs
c'est l'étrange sensation quand et où
les habitués du marché du quai
saint-antoine à lyon ce samedi matin une
action organisée par des militants de
l'association vega d'impact objectif
dénoncer la réalité de l'élevage des
abattoirs jusqu'à l'état l'âge et la
mise à mort quotidienne de plus de 3
millions d'animaux en france que la
viande soit en supermarché ou voix en
marche et il n'y a aucune viande
heureuse
son mât finissent tous au même endroit
et de mort prématurée
donc on veut les sensibiliser là dessus
par une action un peu chocs et un peu de
pédagogie aussi des militants ensuite
parcouru les étals du marché avec des
images chocs d'animaux ensanglanté
provoquant des réactions contrastées
chez les passants certaines personnes
nous remercient pour notre combat nous
disent que c'est bien que nous soyons là
aujourd'hui et d'autres personnes sont
choqués par les images et comme ça c'est
souvent ils ont tendance à nous dire que
c'est pas la bonne méthode parce qu'ils
sentent agressés ils se retrouvent en
dissonance cognitive phase et à ces
images ça les met très mal à l'aise donc
voilà il ya certaines personnes
rejettent d'autres notions simplement
curieux et regarder que les cris qu'on
projette le discours contient
ils sont à l'écouté je pense que ça on
arrive à passer un message
prochain événement pour l'association
vegan impact le 1er août à marseille
avec cette fois une action prévue devant
une boucherie la circulation virale
s'accentue de jour en jour en france
avec plus de mille nouveaux cas de cours
d'un virus par jour les hôpitaux redoute
l'arrivée d'une deuxième vague en pleine
période estivale
pour christophe prudhomme médecin
urgentiste responsable cgt il faut
démocratiser au maximum les tests pour
détecter les personnes contaminées coûté
aux films en totale nous l'avons
critiquer c'est une mesure moyenâgeuse
qui n'étaient motivés que par le manque
de moyens donc la question aujourd'hui
c'est que nous ayons suffisamment de
tests suffisamment de masse mais il
n'est pas question de revenir un
confinement total ce serait une hérésie
que ce soit en termes sanitaires qu'en
termes économiques
il faut qu'on soit en capacité de
détecter les patients et j'insiste
l'urgence aujourd'hui l'urgence et que
les gens puissent se faire tester dans
la journée quand ils ont besoin ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui en france
ce qui n'est pas le cas
le gouvernement nous avait promis au
mois de mai au moment du des compliments
vous avez promis la capacit capacité de
700 vitesse par semaine nous sommes à
moins de 400 mille aujourd'hui deux mois
après pourquoi parce que nous manquons
de matériel les commandes n'ont pas été
faites
les laboratoires n'ont pas été données
doté de moyens
et on tergiverse pour savoir si on peut
faire les tests en pharmacie les
secouristes pourrait faire les
prélèvements mais il faut pouvoir faire
les prélèvements partout c'est assez
simple de faire des prélèvements
donc il faut se donner les moyens pour
effectivement dire aux gens quand ils
partent en vacances et qui viennent une
région où le virus circule et qui vont
dans une région où il ya peu de virus et
bien au moindre doute qu'ils se fassent
tester avant de partir et s'ils sont
positifs et bien ne partent pas
c'est ça aujourd'hui le message qu'il
faut transmettre à la population dans ce
contexte de restrictions sanitaires le
monde de la nuit est en détresse les
discothèques sont fermés depuis le mois
de mars
il en appelle à l'aide du gouvernement à
l'issue d'une nouvelle réunion hier la
création d'un fonds de soutien a été
acté il vise à couvrir les charges fixes
des professionnels du monde de la nuit à
hauteur de 45 mille euros loyer factures
d'eau et d'électricité seront prises en
charge jusqu'à 15000 euros pour une
durée de trois mois
coût total de la mesure 50 millions
d'euros est elle satisfaisante éléments
de réponse avec la patrick malvaes
président du syndicat national des
discothèques pas je peux vous donner des
chiffres très précis malheureusement
actuellement nous avons 300
établissements de envisage de déposer le
client bilan il y en a 38 qui l'ont déjà
fait et ça représente globalement 7 à
8000 personnes qui risquent de se
retrouver
vous m'excuserez la tribalité
l'expression sur le capi 7 à 8 personnes
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé sur
la france aéronautique française et par
contre ils ont eu une aide de cinq
milliards d'euros ce qui peut-être pas
tout à fait comparable
l'enjeu n'est pas non plus le même donc
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
important 8000 personnes en particulier
des jeunes et je veux absolument arrêter
cette hémorragie et je pense qu à fait
ce qu'a fait monsieur alain griset sous
pouvez bien entendu de monsieur bruno le
maire notre ministre des finances est
quelque chose de nature à nous aider
puissamment
le tout c'est de savoir jusqu'à quand ça
va durer cette situation d'insécurité
je veux bien qu aucun doute on
renouvelle et qu'on accroissent encore
les aides mais ce n'est pas une solution
le courant n'avait russes qui continuent
de sévir du côté de l'espagne au
nord-est du pays en catalogne les
autorités sanitaires ont décrété la
fermeture des boîtes de nuit également
et des bars objectif empêcher la
propagation du virus une décision qui
divise les habitants restent d'ailleurs
ambiance estivale du côté de barcelone
écouter un morceau assis en terrasse une
habitude pour les barcelonais les
touristes mais avec l'aggravation de la
crise sanitaire les autorités ont imposé
une limite de dix personnes pour tout
rassemblement
bien sûr pour l'économie pour la santé
pour tous les choses vont mal et ne
feront qu'empirer si les gens ne sont
pas conscients de ce qu'ils doivent
faire des sorties cher aux espagnoles
fortement bouleversé depuis une semaine
puisque les autorités sanitaires ont
ordonné la fermeture des boîtes de nuit
et des théâtres en ce qui concerne la
vie nocturne nos habitudes ont beaucoup
changé
par exemple nous avions une association
de quartier et nous avions l'habitude
d'organiser décidément en plein air et
d'autres activités et avec les nouvelles
règles nous ne pouvons plus le faire par
exemple
la semaine dernière nous avons dû
arrêter la saison de cinéma en plein air
que nous avions commencé parce qu'il y
avait une limite de dix personnes
donc ce n'était pas compatible avec
cette nouvelle norme
une mesure qui s'est étendue au nord-est
de l'espagne désormais c'est près de 7,5
millions de locaux et de touristes qui
trouveront porte close à l'entrée des
bars et des discothèques
c'est bon pour moi nous devons arrêter
le virus d'une manière ou d'une autre
les jeunes sortent le soir boivent se
drogue ne porte pas de masque
il faut que cela cesse d'une manière ou
d'une autre le seul problème est que les
boîtes de nuit une survie
on passe cette année s'il n'y a plus de
travail pour eux je ne pense pas qu'ils
passeront l'année selon les autorités
cette restriction devrait durer au moins
15 jours
rappelons qu'à ce jour l'espagne est
l'un des pays européens les plus touchés
par la pandémie avec plus de 28 mille
morts
pourquoi une rose est dorado
journalistes espagnols cette décision
est un gros coup dur pour les
professionnels de la nuit
80% des personnes et des professionnels
des dès la nuit sont contre cette
décision de forcément puisque pour
beaucoup d'eux c'est la survie des leurs
de leurs affaires à qui est qui et qui
est en jeu c'est vrai que la situation
exigeait des mesures drastiques puisque
comme je vous hisser en 24 heures c'est
plus des miss à autour de 1500 cas
positifs qui ont été déclarés en
catalogne on ne peut plus continuer de
la même façon puisqu'on voit
qu'effectivement les foyers d'infection
en catalogne se multiplient aujourd'hui
dé façon générale en espagne il ya à peu
près 200 foyers qui sont actifs depuis
de foyers tout petits avec une de
personnes jusqu'à des foyers avec
plusieurs milliers comme c'est le cas du
côté des dés la catalogne mais
l'inquiétude
elle est surtout économique puisque
effectivement c'est un dur ces temps
durs à venir à qui attend tous ces
professionnels
mais la population effectivement a
besoin a besoin d'être rassuré et être
rassuré ceux de revenir à une certaine
forme de confinement ou au moins un
contrôle des mouvements qui s'imposent
gerben sonoro annonce qu'il est
désormais négatif au courant des virus
en quarantaine dans sa résidence de
brasilia depuis plusieurs jours le
président brésilien semble bénéficier
d'un regain de popularité
il est donné favori pour l'élection de
2022 par trois nouveaux sondages et ce
malgré une gestion très critiquée de la
crise sanitaire à la bernard même
confiné après avoir été testé positif
aux coronavirus jaillir wolson arrow ne
manque pas une occasion pour s'adresser
à ses supporters comme ici devant sa
résidence à brasilia chaque membre de la
société sera tôt ou tard infectés et il
n'y a aucune façon d'éviter la mort qui
en découlent au brésil de ce que j'ai
personne ne meurt parce qu'il n'a pas
reçu l'attention médicale qu'il faut
plus tôt cette semaine le président
brésilien a été photographiée sans
masque en train de discuter avec des
balayeurs dans les jardins du palais
présidentiel
une légèreté assumée dans les électeurs
ne semblent pas lui tenir rigueur
bien au contraire selon une récente
enquête
43% des personnes interrogées approuvent
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire contre
40%
il y a deux semaines plus significatif
encore un sondage réalisé par le site
conservateur médias indiquent que
jaillir ball sionards au sortirait en
tête lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022
il l'emporterait d'ailleurs au second
tour quel que soit son adversaire
dimanche dernier ils étaient des
centaines dans les rues de brasilia pour
manifester leur soutien au président
après qu'il a été testé positif aux
coronavirus notre président est en
accord avec nos convictions nous avons
perdu beaucoup de temps avec un
président qui n'étaient pas alignés sur
la foi chrétienne
nous sommes aux côtés du président
jaillir messias bolson araud je suis
venue du beurre lendja en moto seul je
ferai tout pour soutenir ball sonar haut
parce que je suis fatigué de voir un
gang s'acharner contre lui et proféré
des mensonges tout le monde le maltraite
et je n'accepte pas c'est pourquoi je ne
reste plus à la maison je suis ici pour
défendre notre président pour défendre
les valeurs chrétiennes de la famille
bray
ils viennent c'est ce que nous voulons
un pays libéré de la corruption libérer
du communisme la crise sanitaire qui
frappe le brésil de plein fouet ne
semble donc pas entamé la ferveur des
partisans de jaillir wolson arrow les
chiffres pourtant sont affolants le pays
concentre à lui seul plus de 2 millions
de cas soit la moitié des personnes
contaminées en amérique latine et pour
en parler nous sommes avec claudio call
fou qui est secrétaire national du parti
de gauche et spécialiste de l'amérique
latine
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors on l'a vu comment expliquer
ces sondages très favorables à jaillir
bolton euros alors que le pays a dépassé
les 85 mille morts alors il a alors
effectivement il a une gestion très très
théâtral de cette de cette crise alors
comment comment l'expliquer il ya
plusieurs raisons la première il est
dans un contexte très particulier il
faut pas oublier que bolton arrow est
arrivé au pouvoir grâce à un système
particulier où la justice politique
s'est occupé de la principale élections
en compagnie des différents médias
quand je parle de la principale
élections du brésil c'est celle de
l'élection présidentielle donc il est
dans un contexte particulier mais en
même temps il faut pas oublier que les
sondages sont sont temporaires et que
l'élection brésilienne et dans deux ans
en tout cas en ce qui concerne les
allées présidentielle et du coup d'ici à
deux ans il ya encore beaucoup de choses
et notamment la crise économique qui
vient souvent après cette crise
sanitaire auquel les brésiliens n'ont
pas encore je dirais eu à subir de com
comme d'autres pays commencent à le
subir mais effectivement là c'est une
véritable c'est une véritable politique
théâtrale que qui essayent de cacher
qu'on va dire la totale incohérence le
déconfite
en tout cas la situation totalement
chaotique de la gestion de cette crise
au brésil c'est assez paradoxal un des
centaines de brésiliens sont sortis dans
les rues de brasilia pour soutenir belle
solara après sa contamination
le président brésilien semble avoir une
base d'électeurs acquise à sa cause
comment comment on explique cette
ferveur autour du président alors du
coup écoutez je je je pense ce goûter où
je regarde plus l'aspect politique sur
sur de bolton euros effectivement il ya
des mots il ya des moments qui il ya des
moments de l'histoire du brésil qui sont
qui sont assez sombres sur différents
points on peut pas se l'expliquer d'une
façon on va dire très très rapide ce qui
est sûr c'est que il profite d'un
contexte particulier qui est celui de
son élection présidentielle et qui est
que c'est le gestionnaire on va dire de
cette de cette crise et je le rappelle
une fois de plus c'est une gestion très
chaotique parce que si on rentre un peu
plus dans les dans les détails et qu'on
est un peu plus dans les villes c'est on
va dire une une multitude de politiques
différentes qui ont été mises en place
en fonction des en fonction des villes
en fonction des en fonction des
différentes provinces c'est un peu comme
avoir un code de la route différenciées
en fonction des villes et en fonction
des régions au lycée en france
voyez c'est une situation qui donne un
contexte assez particulier alors
effectivement il aura toujours des des
partisans de sa de sa cause qui est une
qui est une cause très fascisante on va
dire dans son danse et danse et
expression une cause qui a qui a appelé
justement vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure à limiter collective
c'est très dangereux et en tout cas je
pense que les brésiliens tôt ou tard se
rendront compte de cette situation
chaotique dans lesquelles est en train
de les mener j'ai ailleurs bolton arrow
et ils sont en tout cas nombreux a déjà
s'être rendu compte de cette de cette
situation vous l'avez dit ingestion kawa
chaotique hier du cours d'un virus au
brésil depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire le président brésilien semble
minimiser cette pandémie
même en étant touché lui même il ne
dévie pas de son léger par souci de
cohérence selon vous alors alors après
son vous savez son c'est comme je dis
j'ai le début 6 noeuds
ces différents tests il les a annoncé de
façon théâtrale avoir derrière qu'est ce
qu'il y a qu est-ce qu il ya d être
derrière tout ça c'est avant tout moi ce
que je regarde c'est les chiffres au
niveau du brésil qui on est et qui ont
été rappelés c'est près de on se dirige
doucement vers l'est vers les cent mille
morts il ya plus de 2 millions de
contaminés derrière tout ça c'est une
c'est une gestion qui qui cache beaucoup
de choses vous avez d'un côté la forêt
amazonienne qui continue justement à
ceux à être transformés à être détruite
à à venir à 2 à de nouvelles crises et
de l'autre côté vous avez une
je dirais une image qui est orienté dans
tout l'est dans tous les médias qui est
celle du du président salvateur du
sauveur de la nation
donc pour le moment en tout cas on peut
voir que sur certains sondages ça marche
mais je suis pas sûr que à moyen ou long
terme ceci sera très efficace
merci beaucoup claudio qu'elle fier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national du parti de gauche et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine
situation de la crise politique en
tunisie kaïs ayed a jusqu'à minuit pour
désigner son nouveau chef du
gouvernement
le successeur d'élie espad phare elle
qui a démissionné il y a dix jours sur
fond d'affaires de conflits d'intérêts
hier soir c'est le chef de la diplomatie
qui a quitté son poste
épilogue de plusieurs semaines
d'instabilité les précisions avec
antoine ogi le 6 octobre 2019
le parti islamo-conservateur ennahda
emmenés par rached ghanouchi remporté
les élections législatives devant le
parti politique au coeur de la tunisie
de nabil karoui patron d'un groupe de
médias et de publicité le scrutin qui
avait débuté quelques semaines après la
présidentielle remportée par rail sayed
ovni de la scène politique tunisienne
avait connu une faible participation
- d'un tunisien sur deux s'étaient alors
déplacés aux urnes
c'est dans ce contexte marqué par une
forte abstention kelly et ce par fars
qui n'a obtenu que 0 34% des voix aux
dernières élections présidentielles et
désigne
et après plusieurs mois de tractations
chef du gouvernement par le président
rayess ça y est mais cinq mois plus tard
le 15 juillet 2020 sous la pression du
parti dominant ennahda qui a mis en
avant des soupçons de corruption pesant
sur lui
eliès par fars et contraintes de déposer
sa démission au président rayess sayyed
il signe au passage le plus court mandat
depuis la révolution de 2011
en attendant un successeur il garde ses
fonctions et affirme récemment dans une
interview accordée à express fm qu'on
lui aurait proposé de rester plus
longtemps à la tête du gouvernement
sous certaines conditions on m'a proposé
un accord pour continuer à gouverner
mais je n'ai pas cédé à peine cinq mois
après des négociations difficiles pour
mettre en place un gouvernement
le départ forcé du premier ministre
ouvre la voie de nouvelles négociations
qui s'annoncent compliquées le président
est placée au centre du jeu politique et
doit élire une personne compétente pour
remplacer eliès par fars après
consultations avec les partis politiques
la coalition et les groupes
parlementaires qui entretiennent entre
eux des liens très conflictuelle c'est
une fuite en avant avec le risque que
ces surenchères politiciennes accentue
les tensions sociales au moment où on
nous annonce une croissance en recul de
7% et d'importantes pertes d'emplois
le pays semble s'enfoncer de plus en
plus dans une instabilité politique
alors que la rentrée et toutes les
retombées économiques liées à la crise
du coronavirus et au confinement
approche à grands pas hier deux noms ont
été largement désignés par les partis
politiques siégeant au gouvernement pour
succéder à eliès par fars fadhel
abdelkéfi ancien ministre du
développement et de l'investissement et
ryan turki analystes financiers et
fondateur de plusieurs sociétés et
institutions dans le domaine de créances
financière le président ier sayed
devrait annoncer aujourd'hui le nom du
prochain chef du gouvernement
la personne désignée aura un mois pour
former son gouvernement qui devra
ensuite obtenir la confiance du
parlement
à la majorité absolue d'ici septembre
faute de quoi
l'assemblée sera dissoute et de
nouvelles élections législatives seront
organisées
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité dans un peu plus
de trente minutes
en attendant reste avec tous ses frères
témoins
[Musique]
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
david va permettre à cette
réinitialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mai